welcome back to New Rockstars it's me Mt
and Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3 has
finally released their first trailer
promising all of us that our theater
popcorn will be extra salty as it will
also be flavored with our tears as the
brilliant and Beautiful Mind of Jane's
gun promises to deliver a super
emotional final chapter of the Guardian
Saga and I am not ready for all this to
end please do not kill off rocket please
don't do that I will cry in front of
many women featuring The High
evolutionary as the film's main
antagonist but if some hidden details
that I've noticed in that first trailer
are correct I don't think the high
evolutionary will be the only Cosmic
antagonist the Guardians of the Galaxy
will have to face in this movie in fact
I believe a certain villain from
Guardians of the Galaxy Vol 2 will be
making a surprising return to put the
Guardians of the Galaxy in Crazy danger
and no I'm not just talking about Adam
Warlock who can be seen punching nebula
in the face in the trailer for The Glory
of the Sovereign I'm talking about the
worst father in the MCU by far ego The
Living Planet let's talk about it my
nerd babies because I don't think ego is
dead but first of course should not
forget to hit up new rockstarsmerch.com
to buy one of our cool latest Obsession
shirts or one of our amazing other nerd
options over at that website we have a
lot of cool [ __ ] for you this holiday
season and all of our stuff is the
perfect stocking stuffer for the nerd
that you love so head on over to new
rockstarsmerch.com today to buy
something cool for you and today's video
is sponsored by Babel one of the top
language learning apps in the world the
holidays are all about family one of my
younger cousins just got back from a
semester in Mexico and I want to be able
to surprise her by asking her about her
trip in Spanish which I do not currently
speak at all but that's what Babel is
for Babel specializes in preparing you
for real life encounters and situations
like Studies have shown that 15 hours
using Babel is the equivalent of a
semester of college Spanish in 15 hours
in Babel just flies by like I can watch
videos listen to podcasts play games or
do lessons whatever kind of learning
move that I'm in Babel's got something
that fits the bill I really like how
they gamify learning I have daily goals
and achievements that I can unlock as I
learn the language which which is super
rewarding I'm pretty early in my Babel
Journey but I started to learn some
useful phrases like me tragiste El agun
regalo de Mexico fingers crossed that
she says C get up to 60 off your
subscription when you click the link in
the description or scan the QR code to
start learning with Babel today we thank
Babel again for sponsoring this video
alright so believe it or not I believe
that ego The Living Planet was front and
center in the first trailer for
Guardians 3 because remember that weird
fleshy tentacled mass at the Guardians
of the Galaxy went off to do a dramatic
rainbow colored spacesuit walk into that
weird mass of tentacles is ego of The
Living Planet just an overly evolved
version of ego courtesy of one Herbert
Wyndham aka the high evolutionary who I
like to call Herbert lutionary because
that is his legal name for you see my
nerd babies I believe that this is
Marvel Studios adaptation of a cosmic
being known as superego from the comics
I mean look at him like this [ __ ] looks
exactly like the massive fleshy alien
tentacled planetary Mass the Guardians
are exploring in this movie but first
just what is a super ego anyway well in
the comics superego was described as a
living Cosmic being that the high
evolutionary believed to be the true
source of ego The Living Planet because
in the pages of 4 49 and Thor 450
Herbert lucinary says that he believed
that there was actually multiple Eagle
the living planets in the universe at
one time and that they all originated
from this heavily mysterious solar
system-sized Abomination known as
superego that went around eating planets
with his huge tentacles and my God was
the high evolutionary hype as [ __ ] man
that dude was like yes weird tentacle
creature I want to study it like he
wanted so badly to witness what this
super ego thing was going to evolve into
next because up until that point
superego was apparently going around
consuming entire planets and even ended
up crushing and consuming Eagle The
Living Planet with ease and superego was
so much of a problem in the cosmos that
literally every Celestial in the
universe showed up to address super ego
situation I believe that Guardians of
the Galaxy vol 3 will adapt this event
from the comics for the third Act of the
film when the mad scientist that is the
high evolutionary attempts to do
something that no one in the universe
has ever tried to do create and evolve a
Celestial being using two key factors
here the cosmic remains of Eagle the
living planet combined with all the
celestial material that was mined from
the head of nowhere by The Collector
something that actually brought up in
inside Marvel before the trailer even
premiered because I had the gift of
Prophecy because if you remember from
the first Guardians movie Gamora tells
us that the whole reason why the
collector even set up shop inside of
this huge severed Celestial head was so
that he could mine all the special
Celestial brain matter and spinal fluid
and whatnot to sell on the black market
now I believe that the high evolutionary
bought most if not all of this organic
material and combined it with the
remains of ego The Living Planet that
was thought to be destroyed at the end
of Guardians 2. because here's the deal
guys I don't think Eagle living planet
was actually ever fully dead mostly
because of the way that he died in
Guardians 2 because if you guys remember
Rocket Raccoon had to Fashion a
makeshift bomb using one of the annulax
batteries that he stole from The
Sovereign people now this is extremely
important now because these are the very
same people who use the same golden
yellow type of energy to evolve
themselves into the peak Evolution
people that they are and the very same
energy that Aisha was funneling into her
ultimate weapon of mass destruction Adam
Warlock the peak of evolution now I
believe this because historically in the
MCU yellow energy is the cosmic Infinity
energy Singularity of evolution and I
believe this is the same type of
evolution energy found within the Mind
Stone but just as importantly it's also
the same yellow Cosmic evolutionary that
gives the eternals their powers and the
ability to form a unimi as well as the
Deviant Crow the ability to evolve his
body every time he sipped on an eternal
the eternals had this energy in them
because that yellow Evolution energy
came from Earth's yellow sun which is
exactly what they were charging up in
front of at the beginning of the
eternals movie they were all just
sitting in front of the sun absorbing
all this radiation and then they woke up
and the Sovereign had this solar
Evolution energy themselves because the
entire planet The Sovereign actually sit
on are literally just six yellow Suns
covered by sun-sized domes of Technology
called Dyson spheres that farm solar
Evolution energy like the platform of
anilax Harbor Larry batteries that the
Guardians are protecting at the
beginning of Guardians 2 is where all
the energy that The Sovereign six giant
Suns get funneled into to create
batteries and whatnot this all being
said the bomb that groots hit off in
eco's reign did not destroy ego's brain
completely but instead transformed
mutated and evolved that brain into an
overgrown monstrosity of celestial mass
and tentacles and whatnot which could
very well be the source of this glowing
blue energy at the center of the
circular structure one minute into the
trailer but I was thinking that was
actually the eyeball of nowhere as soon
as I saw it in the trailer I was like
that is the eyeball of nowhere I see you
that's the high evolutionary will
eventually steal from guardians HQ to
make his new and improved evolved
Celestial he's gonna take that head and
use it with ego's brain and just make
one big Celestial I think that's the
plan here basically doing what he did to
Rocket and the new men on a much larger
scale with celestials because as we know
ego's power came from the glowing blue
light of energy inside of his big blue
brain but since that brain got blown up
with a yellow anilax bomb you can see a
faint Golden Glow of energy within the
tendrils of this nowhere eyeball but
speaking of this shot that might be
nowhere's eye check out the patterns of
red and white colors that think organic
tissue is forming into as well as the
background of this shot of the trailer
of the Guardians carrying a wounded Drax
in particular these red plants on the
right of the frame as well as the white
balcony above the plants these are all
features found on ego's planet when the
Guardians first arrive in Guardians 2
with ego's weird look in red plant life
as they land as well as the creamy white
material that ego used to make his white
ship as well as the floating platform
that ego uses to get the Guardians to
his castle so whatever facility the
Guardians are escaping with Drax in the
shot is most likely one of the high
evolutionaries science installation
prisons on the surface of his super ego
creation because these are all elements
found on ego's planet he's red and white
weird organic looking [ __ ] but yes this
is what I believe will be the final end
game of the high evolutionary in
Guardians of the Galaxy Vol 3. to
experiment on the remains of the Dead
celestials nowhere and ego in an attempt
to evolve a Celestial much like the high
evolutionary was interested in doing in
the comics leaving the Guardians of the
Galaxy to deal with a threat that took
an army of celestials to handle in the
comic so you know good [ __ ] luck but
what do you guys think do you guys think
that superego could be showing up at the
end of Guardians of the Galaxy Vol 3.
let us know in the comment section below
but thank you guys so much for watching
this video you can follow me at
mastertonment on Twitter if you guys
want to see me tweet some weird [ __ ] but
most importantly you can follow you rock
stars wherever we are on the social
medias thank you guys so much for
watching I love you guys times a million
and I'll see you guys next time goodbye
[Music]